we're learning more about the gunman who
killed nine people in Dayton Ohio
classmates of Connor Betts tell The
Associated Press he was suspended during
his junior year of high school for
writing a hit list in a bathroom the 24
year old had also been suspended for
having a list of female students he
wanted to sexually assault mul Elena is
in Dayton where he spoke with the
survivor who called the shooting a war
zone molo what else can you tell us at
this time about the investigation well
good morning tarika police say they have
found at least 41 empty K shell shell
casings out here on Fifth Street they
say the gunman may have had up to 250
rounds of ammo on him but they stressed
it in such a chaotic scene as it was out
here on Fifth Street evidence can easily
get lost cell phone video that you're
seeing right now shows the pure chaos
from inside Ned peppers bar right behind
me here in the Oregon district police
killed the gunman moments before he
stormed into the bar where as you can
imagine things could have gotten
significantly worse I sat down with the
shooting survivor
Anthony Reynolds he had just left Ned
peppers when the shooter opened fire but
soon before I could think I just hear
rapid fire you just hear the gunshots
so then I just start running because I
don't know where they coming from so you
don't know which way to run
I don't know which way to run but I
still run west because I'm leaving
running towards my car you can see
people just start falling that's the gun
I was going so then I knew of my people
getting hit it saw instantly they start
screaming to the crowd
run man shooter this was chaos yeah so
much chaos and I just see the security
guards trying to pull people out of the
club you see people trying to give him a
CPR no matter what environment what vu
you're not safe because people are able
to get these type of weapons and just
come and change your life in a matter of
seconds 24 seconds it's all it took
right it's all they took 24 seconds
a rental says when he came out of the
bar he was about 10 feet away from
people lined up outside the bar he says
he saw some of those people actually get
shot father of two told me that just a
few more seconds inside that bar and he
thinks he could have been one of those
people Anthony mola thank you